there really is no end to the bottomless
pit that is reality tv and to prove this
point in january
tlc is coming out with a show called my
husband's
not gay let's take a look
i like to say i've chosen an alternative
to an alternative lifestyle
i'm attracted to my wife for sure and
i'm definitely attracted to men too he's
a good looking guy for sure
well i'm interested in men i'm just not
interested in men that's clear
so are they gay or not i get a little
defensive when somebody calls my husband
gay
the whole act is against the teachings
of the gospel i want to marry a woman
but i don't know how to work out these
feelings
i don't know how to tell you this but
i'm attracted to men
you think sorry dave yeah please feel
this one before i punch someone
yeah you think maybe she had a clue what
was coming because there was a camera
there in her face
something might be it might not be just
a normal day where he tells her that he
loves her
you think it was actually like they were
up to something this is
just i mean i hate reality television it
it doesn't end every time we think that
it can't get worse it actually does get
worse
and keeps showing us just more twisted
values and blah blah blah
but this like really seems like the
worst because the gay thing i'm so over
it i think the country's over it nobody
wants to talk about it anymore
let's get these last couple states to
defend and then equality and bla and
that's it and big goddamn deal
so to me this coming out like what come
on
i actually don't mind this reality show
as much as others because i think that
it does shine a light on a really
serious issue which is
hiding who you really are because you
want to appease those in your religious
group yeah and
when i watched the trailer for that
special i actually got
really upset at the women who know that
their husband is gay
and they're enabling this like denial of
who they really are by marrying them
like if some guy came to me and said
hey you know let's say i'm in love with
him right and he says look i'm super
religious
and i really want to marry you but the
reality is i'm attracted to men
i'd be like look i love you too and this
is devastating
but i'm not gonna have you marry me and
hide who you really are
be free right so so i and i get it the
religion is what convinces these people
that they're doing the right thing
they're not doing the right thing this
is terrible
just flip it on its head imagine if you
as a straight person
are forced to have same-sex relations
because your religion says that's the
right thing to do can you imagine that i
mean
me as a straight woman can't even
imagine having sex with a woman because
i have no interest in women right
so doing that to appease anyone is
absolutely ridiculous yeah
these are presbyterians who do that
right exactly
again that's either some sort of
processing though yeah um
i i like anna's point about that this
almost seems worse for the women than
for the man like the men are conflicted
there's this internal whatever
and the women are sort of taking
advantage in a weird way they're preying
on it
praying upon it it seems kind of
terrible i mean the religion is preying
upon it
the mormons also have a video out i
guess now about how
not to masturbate um that's good advice
yeah um you know uh this woman i loved
there was in that clip she goes uh
i get a little defensive when someone
calls my husband gay
well you're about to be uh on a show
called
my husband it's gonna happen a lot
more because your husband is totally gay
he's gay so
why do these people agree to do this is
this purely just everyone wants their 15
minutes
and that's it like is that really what
this is about or is do you think this is
really in their hearts they're both the
men are like i can
beat this and the women are like i can i
did a story on this in
in 1999 and maybe even late 98 in miami
where i met
jenk um he was not involved with this
group but we did it
this was this was excellent this was the
early days at least of coverage of
exodus international which was
a leading if not the leading gay
conversion therapy
and i went to a meeting with these guys
and sat in and talked to the
leader of the group who you know was as
gay as the day is long but insisted
no no not at all but what he had done
tragically was just shut down
he was like oh i've been celibate for 23
years no no i'm not just my choice
you know and then there were these guys
and these guys were stru
i don't know whether any of them are
still some were in relationships some
just wanted to be
and it was just unbelievably painful one
guy got out right after the video and
called and was like i just want to let
you know i
turns out i'm just gay and i'm just
gonna be gay and i'm
happier and you were like oh thank god
so but i think that these guys were
sincere in their desire you know these
are guys whose faith is so strong in
this case it
happens to be mormonism but we could in
and we could
write in almost any other faith um
their faith is so strong uh their their
belief in their
in their religion is strong and the
condemnation from the people they admire
is so complete and
without moderation that they think this
is the way
i can do this i mean you know you guys
all the time whenever you've got
something in your life that you want to
get rid of how many times have you said
i know it's certainly true for me
that i've said 250 times
that was the last time i'm doing this
right now i'm going to get my [ __ ]
together
you know this is a gambling thing here i
think you're it's actually a lot of
things
yeah but gambling has been one actually
that one i don't mind
um uh although the warriors last night
come on
okay anyway so uh no one could have seen
that coming so but so i believe it is
sincere and i believe they think they
can do it
the tragedy is that that there's a the
alternative
to their alternative to the alternative
is just
hey you could probably be happy and you
could probably be happy with
megan's husband that's why that's why i
don't want to be totally glib about this
because i do
obviously feel a lot of empathy for
these guys and i was closeted so i know
what that's like but why don't we see
this with women what is that
like something here actually shows me
that there is something a little more
involved
with women because you do hear about
women all the time i know women that
in their mid 40s 50s they suddenly get
divorced and then they
are openly gay they're with other women
yet with men there definitely seems to
be more of this thing where you can like
push it down and of course that happens
with men too but it
as a rule i think you see more of women
accepting sexuality more
i think it has a lot to do with the
differences in male and female sexuality
they're not the same
but i think a bigger reason behind that
is just societal expectations and
societal norms
so whenever you hear right wingers talk
about
gay marriage and you know they try to
like make a case against it
they talk about gay sex but they never
talk about gay sex between two women
they talk about gay sex between two men
there's a lot of stigma between men
experimenting with their sexuality
whereas women are free to experiment
with it and it's considered sexy and
titillating right that's why every girl
in college can make out
and put it on condemned scissoring you
know
you know that's not that's not he
doesn't talk about that yeah that's not
that's not the issue yeah it's
exactly what you say anna that there's
still
you know women who experiment with other
women
never ever and thankfully have their
femininity questioned men who experiment
with other men
are not men yeah instantly you know in
the eyes of many and in the eyes of
maybe even still most of society
like we know you're supposed to embrace
it and it's okay
but come on he's not a man yeah so and
that that really has not
changed very much while this other rapid
growth
in gay rights that that that stigma
still
holds i think to a large extent so last
point on this is that really because the
next step of this is
that you're going to have to actually
start seeing gay people have some sort
of affection
on television or in movies because we
still don't everyone says uh i'm for gay
stuff
blah blah blah blah but even on modern
family as i've mentioned a bunch on the
show
they had a situation where one of the
guys has a fear of public displays of
affection
it's an easy way to write off i'm not
i'm not judging the writers but it's an
easy way to write off like ah we don't
have to do that that ick factor as marny
frank called it so we need that right
like is that kind of the next uh yeah i
think i think that with more and more
people
um accepting gay marriage and
understanding that gay rights is not
just a gay rights
issue it's a civil rights issue you're
going to start seeing that reflected in
media more
and you know it's it's a slow transition
but i definitely see that happening have
you seen looking on hbo
i feel like i'm living it so i didn't
watch it i know people i know they
played the golden girl theme song at the
end of the last episode people were very
excited
those guys uh because i mean they're not
they're not hiding anything there's no
modern family
it's hbo but those guys aren't just gay
those guys are gay like